hello welcome my name is markiplier no
good intro monkey me a monkey
okay so this is ancestors right the
humankind odyssey
i don't know if this game is about
evolving from
early
what's the word
what's the word isn't there a word for
like
old ancestor apes not apes
not monkeys the ones back in the dead
the common ancestor is that the word i'm
looking for i don't know i don't know if
there
this game is all about going from that
to this but it sounds like it
lineage name
[Music]
[Laughter]
as opposed to homo sapiens you idiots
choose level of assistance total useful
immersive riveting
i kind of want a riveting experience i
don't know if
that means i will be riveted into the
dirt starting character gender let's
roll the dice why not
homo he who first time hidden waterfall
oasis
female clan size medium species
i don't know i don't know what this is
going to be inspired by
true events i don't know if these events
are going to be inspired by true events
the world and characters you will
encounter are not men are meant to
represent archetypes of a place in a
moment
not the exact depiction of what happens
latest scientific discoveries were used
as guidelines and i'm gonna really bend
those guidelines
you got guidelines i've got bending to
do
am i gonna have to engage in crazy
monkey sex is that like a main feature
of this game
i'm not opposed to it but just wondering
what to prepare myself for
use your body senses mind and voice to
guide your voyages oh
gain strength in numbers and advanced
species ape together
strong good luck we won't help you much
i hope not at all
this is a lot farther out than i thought
we'd start
it well this is interesting
oh my god
was that a laser was that a laser in the
sky what was that
man nature's messed up man oh my god
that's terrifying
god oh my god
holy crap
okay so the moral of the story is
everything dies
and your death is inopportune no way get
him
wow man
gator should have paid attention i
suppose there it goes
man that poor fish
i can yeah all right
i'm getting it i'm into it
lesson is i'm about to die a lot
volume one before us don't eat
you don't know where it's been you have
no idea
is that my baby my monkey baby don't
worry kid you're gonna eat good tonight
i just found a fish
delicious whoa
[Music]
i don't think i needed to go that far
wow holy [ __ ] oh my god
holy crap oh my god
oh i'm the baby i get it
mom yeah as i've learned
what the hell is that oh my god
holy crap horrible oh my god i'm gonna
die
i mean i it makes sense yeah if you just
a monkey out in the middle of nowhere
with
no parental figure you're gonna uh be at
the mercy of the whims of the jungle and
i am
currently at the mercy of the whims the
whims have me in their clutches
where do i go what do i do oh should i
climb i guess i might
want to climb do i just grab on and go
for it uh
that feels like a good first instinct
i'm going for it okay climbing
i'm climbing oh my god this is the
scariest game i've ever played in my
life all right i'm up here what are you
doing over there
sure wish the experience wasn't quite so
riveting
okay well i guess up high isn't
guaranteed to be safe i'm jumping for it
jumping oh [ __ ] oh my god i just
remembered my whole mom
got by bird so you know
cue this lion king soundtrack is this a
circle of life
oh my god i'm alive my poor baby bones
i'm just going to go for it these these
[ __ ] don't know what's
ready for them which is me and they
they're
they have no idea what's coming for them
for all my fear of the jungle there sure
ain't much happening
kind of empty now that i'm looking at it
pretty
hold on nothing kinda actually just like
nothing
oh what oh what's happening
did i make it am i somewhere good
am i somewhere bad where am i
i got a call oh i can hear i'm learning
i'm communicating ape together
strong
if only my mom didn't go so far away to
eat a
chewed fish maybe i wouldn't be coming
back alone
hello family cousins
yep family
woo whoa
where are you okay they're definitely up
there but how in the world how in the
world
i hear a mystical thanks monkey but i
hear a mystical something
oh is that food i find food num nums
num nums oh num nums how do i eat it
how do i eat it do i eat it do i not eat
it
oh there's like a path oh
man maybe i shouldn't have this coconut
but i can't seem to drop it anymore so
i'm just gonna hold on to it oh yeah
they don't like that oh i can climb the
mountain
oh well that's easier okay well that
makes my life a lot easier
can i eat this can i eat can i eat eat
what did i do what what
what wait sorry run that by me again
i didn't know i had supervision how did
i well i don't have adult supervision
but i didn't what
no don't lie to me you you did that i
dropped the
coconut but it said they were like down
there were they down there
am i stupid how stupid am i let me look
i'm stupid there you are incoming
sploosh perfectly safe
well oh mom's dead what can you do
time for it hey friend hey how you doing
good to see ya
i'm assuming this is sad emotions more
remorse and regret and loss and pain and
i was getting that
ah yes hello everybody hi what's up
hey what's going on hey how you doing
oh why what happened oh
i'm on your back now uh i guess you're
my new
mom question mark dad hard to say
parental figure okay oh that's how you
do that
okay you go q mode and then you go
e mode okay there's some going on there
something weird's happening there that's
that's bizarre
oh it's like a threat like it could be a
monster huh
it must be me smelling you know must be
sniffing gotta be sniff snopping i don't
know
oh i got a leaf hey kid i gotta leave
you jealousy yeah you should be
little sniff sniffing hello
how are you listen anyone ever tell you
ape together strong
it's true it's very true how you doing
over here hey what's up
hey how you doing hey what's up hey you
doing hey what's going on hey how you
doing you want a leaf
all right good talk okay so what would a
monkey want
right food i'm guessing number one
priority has got to be like food or
something
so there's got to be a button to drop
unless i want to take this leaf with me
leaf no bush thorn bush
some diamonds over there i don't know
what that's about whoa
i don't know what is it what is this
wham i don't know what's that
wow hominid what about you let me
give you a sniff oh no
yeah hominid okay all right hominid i'm
gonna go to the diamond cause i don't
see
much else to do there's gotta be
something cool down there right
well let me grab one grab on oh god
very scary
okay navigating uh jumps zoo oh my god
i'm so
good at everything what are you doing
you playing tag oh
all right whatever hmm what is that
splunk hiding spot oh
really wow oh hi
hello this is my spot what are you doing
there hey what's going on
excuse my butt how you doing
you uh having a good time
what am i doing what am i doing i don't
know what's happening
what what was that oh i changed my
sensation okay i think this must be
hearing right
this must be my ear balls ah and this
must be smell-o-vision
oh there's both of you hi
okay great oh
oh your name is ooh hi
single you're single are you i don't
know what i am so
technically i'm the one on the back but
whatever what is that frog get get it
get the frog get the goddamn frog it's a
freaking frog
can i have it i got a leaf i can't
possibly have a frog let me go to the
hiding spot
maybe that'd be pretty cool it's over
there somewhere
ah god god don't want to get my shoes
wet oh
god
is this it why do i hear drums why do i
hear boss music
oh hi hello you still following me
i help you what's your deal oh wait did
i like
summon them before when i was in camper
those are the ones that like
i was oh oh interesting
it was that what is that
oh hi oh you're a pig oh my god no am i
dead i'm alive
you will never you will never stop me
well if i had any sort of spear i could
have done something about that probably
oh my knee
oh my legs my leg or uh your leg
not technically my leg giant warthog
metrodio
wow oh hi hello youtube how are you
doing you
you good guys i don't know if you're
following me
i really have led you astray i know i
have natural charismatic qualities
but i am vampirically commanding this
ape
through its back so uh i'm actually the
baby
sorry yeah you're fine let's get back
let's get back to camp successful
mission guys
successful mission whoa i know a coconut
tree by the way
hey treats on me nuts on me guys nuts on
me
you want nuts i know a place i know the
hookup
all right let's get this nut pretty
tough to climb one-handed but i managed
to make it look easy
oh yeah yeah look good look good yeah
looking good excuse me
yeah go get your nuts guys go get them i
eat this
how do i i don't know how to do anything
in this game i i should have added like
a hud or something the riveting
experience is a little too riveting
what is happening am i what's going on i
seem to be
delirious man i am not doing good
we are in this baby is cursed
hey guess who's back
yeah did you miss me hi i'm back okay
time for a nice
nap have we discovered fire yet
is there a way to can i oh here we go
okay hold space to sprint what i'm
guessing i can't do that because i'm
all like you know injured oh i'm picking
up speed broken bones be damned
bam [ __ ] get out of my way oh
yeah you wish you wish you wish you
could be as surprised me
my leg's broken screw you all right how
do i eat this
can i eat this smash it up against a
rock or something
you know what you know what i'm going
i'm going
full hud i'm not gonna go tutorial even
though i should i don't know why i did
whoa look at all this information oh my
god tool tips
eat time inspect
i press q a million times
new food discovery cocos
coco drupa great and now i know how to
control
man instantaneously i feel so much more
connected to this goddamn
game focus
remember i rem i remember that
i'm remembering what dead hominid
i will remember that oh that must be uh
uh uh you know uh uh mom
let's go pay mom a visit
i'm coming mom maybe i could have
rescued you at some point around in the
past
but i didn't oh it's you're in the nest
i probably shouldn't
whoa oh i probably shouldn't be here
hello ah
yes there you are all right i hope i
catch that okay
well that's really sad
identified matured ner
my my nerf
[Music]
[Applause]
you know now that i think about that
that makes sense is that baby like
coming back or
what what let's see let's engage these
brain bundles wait what am i
i'm a female coupled with poo with poo
i'm yah coupled with poo hey don't mind
me just
giving a good sniff are you whoo i can't
tell it's not looking at you
well i mean it's looking at you and not
your i grabbed a stick
nah oh bureau where's pooh
whoo you running off without
not you where's poo
there you are god damn it take this
stick
it's yours now i'm gonna groom you
how do i groom i'm grooming you you're
welcome
you're welcome you're welcome
you're welcome am i eating bugs is that
what i'm doing i'm eating i'm eating
bugs
we got an analyst supply food if we just
eat each other's bugs if you think about
it
if you really put your brain to it and i
am not all my brain is 100 capacity
right now
just eating these bugs but if you think
about it hey what the hell
at least my neurons have matured okay
all right you're happy now uh oh my
vision's getting nice and cloudy okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna memorize this
because i wanna not forget where we is
and i'm gonna memorize you pooh so i
don't forget i know i keep looking at
your face and i don't really remember
is that pooh okay i'm memorizing your
face
okay husband i've remembered you
lie down this there's a problem you have
to hold things
i didn't realize that was like a like an
ordeal
i'm sleeping now where'd that baby go
oh yana-rama anyway i'm up and at them
time to attack the day
pooh hey wanna make babies
i don't know whatever shut up go away
i'm gonna get some
nuts so what about my whole neuron thing
a hominid without dopamine risks his
sanity when facing fears hysteria is
waiting
wow that's true across all
time
there were eggs in that nest you know
probably some pretty tasty eggs so
what's up with this
bush right this bush okay i'm analyzing
this bush
painful very prickly you know you know
what i mean very prickly
ah not that prickly apparently i thought
it might be a little more than that i'm
hungry where are those cocoa nuts
i want to go nuts for coconuts you know
what i mean
whoa buddy
oh my god my leg ow
i am a terrible leap i'm terrible i'm
bad i'm the worst date my god i'm not
doing okay
what are wrong with me help i'm just
gonna get a coco nut and i'm gonna go go
nut out of here
oh my god now there's two dead up there
interesting two oh two's up there wait
what
oh my god there's the baby's still up
there how my broken leg
i gotta go get that baby i will rescue
you there you are
okay i'm focused i'm gonna memorize a
bam
i'm on the way baby okay i just gotta go
up that that tree actually
oh oh no not again not again not again
oh my god you know what the whole
jumping
to treat a tree thing probably not the
best move i need this
in and out i can't have three dead apes
in this
nest if we can't be over three on this
for the sake of the species we really
gotta get moving on this
i mean this broken bone is uh definitely
ain't good but
you know we'll be fine oh i was the
wrong tree actually
i was actually incorrect about this one
all right don't worry i'm priming the
jump
missed it by that much
my god
good god my green circle is really blank
and hard inside my
not green well that's now the green's
gone is my like
grip strength about to fall or something
i don't like the idea of that okay let's
take a breather take a breather
wow okay we're gonna drop this screw
that all right baby
don't worry rescue on the way
the bees the bees i'm gonna grab it
i got it that baby's just sitting there
aren't you all right
i'll be right there yeah
oh my god okay in and out in and out
real quick real quick
baby come here baby now now is the time
now jump into my arms
if you can jump just jump jump baby
please we gotta go we gotta go like
yesterday
we gotta go literally yesterday come
here handle no pick it back how do i
right no no don't rename i'm not worried
about the name right now
oh my god what do i do oh wait oh i'm
running
[Music]
i panicked the first thing about life in
the jungle is not to panic
okay this time we're gonna get in swoop
in
not rename the baby okay now we've got
it
this time we are definitely in it to win
okay baby
let's go baby let's go okay piggyback
piggyback okay we're out of here yes
okay mission's successful
eat it well don't eat it bird
idiot man i feel full-on monkey now
and i got a beehive question mark
you know today was a good day don't know
if you guys knew this but day
good day good day today hey pooh
i got us a new kid who is that
some floozy with my poo i am
dying i don't know what is how am i
starving hungry
eat the thing in your hand i don't know
hey pearl are you with this floozy
are you lily is that is that you
i uh honestly i don't really remember
faces too much
sure wish i could tell what you are
from the proper distance who are you
who the hell are you analyze
it's poo god you could have just said so
you know you could have said so
i'm gonna lay down how do i get this
goddamn kid off my back
whoo man just be sure wish i could do
anything can i how do i inspect this i'm
so trying to s inspect
what's in my hand but i will never do it
for as long
as i live i will never do it i refuse it
is
just that important that i don't i want
everyone to know this i'm declaring it
actually
i will never know what's in my hand i
refuse to use my intelligence at all
let's try this again let's try this
again okay okay all right
let's try this again okay we're going
total random start
just because i need to get my foot in
the door somehow
i would love to bash my head again so
you know what
i am not like my this is what it's all
about people
who don't you get get out i'm going back
you almost got me game
you almost got me you almost got me but
i will not be swayed because
me and big smart all i need to do is
think about
how it would really be i don't need
anyone to explain
this game because that's not what this
is about no no
no that's not what this is about what
this is about
is embracing
what it was to be an early
soon-to-be human don't move it to stay
in intelligence look around
dismiss i don't need it okay who am i
what i'm different now
avatar's vitality this is
that it's because i turned the tutorial
on this that's very helpful
god damn that that is helpful okay
reduces poison that is
limited by avatar's age okay that's very
helpful
and updates after sleeping of for one
hour more hinges on a healthy lifestyle
wow that's super yeah neuronal energy
having children nearby allows the
accumulation of
gotta suck the energy right out here
more children round means more
accumulation
sure i would have figured that out just
by playing the game definitely
intelligence could be used practical
items and to visualize things the things
you have identified
i very a very helpful god damn that's
helpful
evolution oh my god
this is so helpful wow look at this
i'm gonna pump out my neurons oh
[ __ ] my neurons are pumping dude my
neurons are
bump baby genetic potential 2 has an
increased capacity to metabolize food
nice this is great this is great
hey you call me yeah pooh get over here
okay don't rush or anything
[Music]
oh so the ceiling is really interesting
well that was great
new records three seconds good job man
uh let me
just all right we crank that out i gotta
crank out my neurons
the neuron can't be initiated because
you don't have neuronal energy carrying
kids while performing actions
it's the only way to generate sure is
everyone knows this
does that mean i gotta have a kid on my
back while we uh
mate hey you who are you who the hell
doesn't matter come here you
all right let's go get some neuronal
energy
we suck in some neurons there huh i
don't know what that is all about
sucking the neurons ooh neurons suckage
blam oh look at the dead bodies oh the
kid is still up there
okay how do i get this goddamn kid off
my back
get this goddamn kid off my back
hold q to inspect well that's funny
hold q hold
q hold q
rock hold queue
new tool yeah a new tool absi obsidian i
know the difference between a rock and
obsidian apparently i don't know what
exactly to do about
i can use this to bash open a coco nut
all right i'm turning off tutorials
because i now officially know exactly
everything that i need to play this game
to its fullest potential
get out of here [ __ ] i already know
how to eat
identify well i don't know how to eat i
don't know how to identify and
[ __ ] now if i could just figure out how
to get this kid off my maybe if i jump
from a high enough precipice the kid
will
mysteriously disappear from my back hey
uh other kid
where are you at where are you at ah
there you are okay
mother ya father pooh but
but that's impossible get this again
grab that
say let's inspect this
strange
oh it's not a beehive at all it's some
fiber
thing uh kid i don't know if i can carry
two kids on my back
well let's find out kid uh
i'm gonna apply this on you i guess no
i'm on myself
okay i'm gonna run uh because apparently
i'm an idiot drop that
did i just try to it oh i thought i was
trying to attack someone with it
okay kid um okay analyze clan member
well it's a little late for them uh okay
kid kid all right you know what nope i i
hear some flapping
that kid's fine oh this is the same
goddamn thing
okay i'm guessing i just can't do
anything
oh it's a food african giant mom bin
i love mom bins who doesn't love mom
bins let me eat this up
nah kid shut up shut up i'm eating
it's my neurons my neurons are going to
grow wow
simulated nutrients from the droop kind
of food great
that sounds like a feat every one of
these is mine case
stupid idiot shouldn't have been born a
child should have been
should have been an adult so can i do
like literally anything about this
baby situation uh apparently not okay
i'm gonna grab one of these eggs though
can i grab an egg i got a neck i've got
i got it baby oh i got it that
bird's gonna be so mad but it don't
matter i got the egg oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] hey you killed one of ours
i'm gonna eat your babies look at this
thing look at this look at that i bet
it's delicious i
bet it's delicious i bet it's fantastic
yes i'm gonna eat the it's come full
circle batch
i don't feel good oh man i don't
feel good from that that's raw egg
probably not i'm a lie
down drop oh drop child
bye evolution
this game is now starting to get
fantastic
i am all about it oh can a
aesthetic kinesics
wow gather all clan members and have
them follow you that's
amazing i don't know if i want to do
that i've kind of led people that are
deaf
but i'm gonna i'm gonna call this one
a good place to stop i have successfully
eaten two pairs three pairs it only
killed two other apes
abandoned a baby in a nest as a
distraction and
i have exploded my neurons and
pooh has exploded
anyway thank you for watching
this it's weirdly fascinating you know
it is weirdly fascinating i had no idea
what it's about but now that i'm here
i'm kind of i don't know it's weirdly
fun
maybe i could eventually uh try to
figure out a way to make this
all the way to humanity or so i don't
even know if that's is that an option is
that a thing that can happen i have no
idea thank you everybody so much for
watching if you like this
let me know down below if you want more
of it let me know down below
i'll i'll just leave this one up to you
guys so thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]
you